IN THIS ONE- YEAH ALL THREE-
YES JUST A LITTLE ON THE RED
ONE. HE THAT'S RIGHT HEY I
APPRECIATE IT DIDN'T HELP US
MOVE THINGS ALONG. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO THE
JUNE SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING THIS
HEARING FROM THEIR OFFICES WE
NEED ONE MORE FOR QUORUM SO
PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. WE SEEK TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION AND
DECISIONS. ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA. DUE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WE HAVE A LIMITED SPACE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN
ENSURE EVERYONE MAINTAIN SIXTY
TO SOCIAL DISTANCE. THIS YEAR
PROTESTERS APPEARED AT
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS REMOVING
THE MASKS YELLING FROM THE
AUDIENCE. AND IT'S A VEILED
THREATS ABOUT POTENTIAL GUN
VIOLENCE. AS WE PROCEED WITH
THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING. WE
APPLY THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATE IN PROCEEDINGS.
IN ADDITION. WE CONTINUE TO
COMPLY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS ARISING OUT OF THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARINGS
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC. AS
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME
WILL NOT PERMIT. PERMIT CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. WILL NOT ACCEPT
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR
THAT INCITES OR THREATENS
VIOLENCE. EVEN VEILED THREATS.
IF YOU CAME TO THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY SERGEANTS DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION REFER POSTED
OUTSIDE THE DOOR. THE RULES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING INCLUDE WEARING
A MASK OVER YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE
AT ALL TIMES AND COMPLYING WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. NO TALKING
ALLOWED NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AND IS PERMITTED
BY THE CHAIR. PUBLIC COMMENT
MUST RELATE TO THE BILL BEING
DISCUSSED. NO ENGAGING IN
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING. PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES NICE. MAY SUBJECT
YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THE
COMMITTEE HAS FOR BILLS ON ITS
AGENDA TODAY. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMMITTEE. IS
ABLE TO COMPLETE ITS BUSINESS
ON THE A LOT OF TIME WE'RE
LIMITING PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
FOLLOWS THERE WILL BE A MAXIMUM
OF TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EACH BILL INTO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO EACH BILL WITH A LIMIT. OF
TWO MINUTES PER PRIMARY WITNESS.
AFTER WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES THE PUBLIC.
WILL HAVE. UP TO THIRTY MINUTES
IN TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ON EACH BILL.
STARTING WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CORE HERE IN THE
ROOM. THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT IF
ANY OTHER POSITION ON THE BILL
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL BE
RULED OUT OF ORDER. I DID NOT
MAKE A DECISION TO IMPOSE A
SOUND SLIGHTLY. HOWEVER GIVEN
THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS FOR HEARINGS
IT IS NECESSARY TO ORDER TO
ENSURE. THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
TIME FOR APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILLS IN
THE COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION.
IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THE BILL WANT TO BREAK THERE
FOR A MINUTE JUST TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE. BERMAN HERE MATHIS
HERE. MATHIS HERE BENNETT.
BENNETT HERE LOW. HERE WELL
HERE MAYES. THE MULLIN. THE
BLANCA. HERE WE HAVE A FOUR FOR
THE GREAT SO WE HAVE A CORE FOR
THOSE ARE WATCHING THIS
REMOTELY AND WHO WISH TO CALL
IN TO REGISTER THEIR POSITION
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMIATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SAN
DISTORTION IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2094 MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO BEING MINDFUL
AND RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE FACE. BEFORE
MOVING ON TO THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA FOR TODAY I HAVE ONE
OTHER ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE I
HAVE A LETTER FROM THE SPEAKER
APPOINTING MY DEAR FRIEND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS TO THE
COMMITTEE TO REPLACE MR SAY ARE
TO FOR THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
HEARING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US. WITH ALL THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE WAY WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA LET'S SAY
THE COMMITTEES CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE'S ONE BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT BILLS ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB. FIVE NINETY GOT A
MOTION. GOT A SECOND. AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AS
DETAILED IN COMMON NUMBER FIVE
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH
I'M SURE THE MOTION. AND SECOND
INCLUDED THANK YOU. WE GOT THE
MOTION WE GOT THE SECOND CAN WE
HAVE A VOTE PLEASE MADAM
SECRETARY. THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BERMAN. HI BERMAN I
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE BENNETT.
BENNETT I LOW. LOW ON MAYES.
MULLIN BLOCK RUBIO. BLANCA
RUBIO I. GREAT SO THAT PASSES
FIVE TWO ZERO- WITH FIVE VOTES
AND ALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TWO THREE
YEP THAT'S FIVE. AT THIS POINT
WE DO NOT WE DO HAVE A FORM
WILL MOVE NOW MOVE ON TO THE
OTHER BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA. THE FIRST ITEM ON THE
AGENDA IS SB THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR AMBERG MOVED BILL. GOT
A MOTION AND A SECOND SEND
ARMORED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU- MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY
LITTLE LONG TIME AGO THAT WHEN
YOU'RE AHEAD YOU DON'T CONTINUE
TO TALK SO- URGENT I VOTE. AND
THIS CLARIFY ON THE RECORD THAT
THE- MOTION AND SECOND OR WITH
THE AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED. AND
IS A GOOD CENTERS GOOD WITH
THAT. AND WITH THAT I'M NOT
GONNA SPEAK EITHER GOOD BILL I
SUGGEST AN AYE VOTE- MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OKAY WELL WITNESSES
WE WERE WE ARE AT WAR EVERYBODY
EVERYBODY WAS WAS FEELING SO
SUPPORTIVE OF THINGS DO WE HAVE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE DO WE DO WE HAVE OF
GREGORY DHEAS- REGISTER VOTERS
FOR NEVADA COUNTY AND ROCKS
ANNA CASTRO COMMITTEE PROGRAM
SPECIALIST AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS GREGORY AND
ROXANA I APOLOGIZE FOR
THREATENING TO SKIP OVER YOU-
BUT WE WILL NOW GO TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. VIA THE TELEPHONE.
IF WE HAVE AN OPERATOR BY.
OPERATOR. DO WE HAVE IN YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN THERE IT IS
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN THANK YOU. THIRTY AS YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AS WELL AS OF
CASTING A LINE IS OPEN- HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. A YES WE CAN
HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YES.
I'M ABOUT SHOULD I BEGIN YES
YES THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
DISTINGUISH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK- MY
NAME IS GREGORY DíAS FROM THE
COUNTY CLERK RECORDER AND
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS FROM THE
BATIC. WHAT SUPPORT AT THREE
THIRTY FIVE. NEVADA COUNTY IS
ONE OF FIFTEEN COMING SENATE
MINISTERS SELECTIONS UNDER THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT. UNDER THE
BCA WE OFFER SEVERAL OPTIONS
FOR RETURNING A VOTED BALLOT.
INCLUDING BE A BENEFICIAL
DROPBOX. DEMOCRATIC COUNTY
APPROXIMATELY 50% RETURN
BALLOTS FROM THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION WILL
RETURN VIA DROPBOX. SB THIRTY
FIVE PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY AND AFFORDS DROP BOXES
WILL BUCK PROTECTIONS AGAINST
ELECTION NEARING. IT ALSO MAKES
CLEAR THAT ELECTION OFFICIALS
ESTABLISH DROP BOXES. AND NO
ONE ELSE. DURING THE EARLY
PERIOD LAST YEAR I SATURDAY
POOL OF THE RALLY OF AROUND
HUNDRED TRUMP TO. GATHER IN THE
PARKING LOT GOOD PRINCIPLES
BLOCK ACCESS TO THE DROP BOX IN
OUR PARKING LOT WHICH AT THE
ENTRANCE TO THE OUTSIDE OF THE
CURRENT ONE HUNDRED FOOT
ELECTIONEERING BOPPERS OF. ALL
ADVOCATE HAD ENGAGED IN SOME
FORM OF PROHIBITED ELECTION.
SUCH AS LARGE FLAGS WITH THE
CANDIDATE'S NAME AND LIKENESS
DECORATING NEARLY EVERY CAR ARE
HAPPY T. SHIRT BUTTONED BURKE
AMPLIFIED POLITICAL SPEECH SO I
COULD HEAR FROM THE SECOND
FLOOR OF MY OFFICE. UPSET
BUILDERS CALLED MAYBE PUTTING
THAT COULD NOT COPE TO DROPBOX
OR FELT INTIMIDATED APPROACHING
THE DROP BOX WHILE THE RALLY
WAS TAKING PLACE. FOR BOATERS
ARE TO BE ABLE TO DROP OFF
THEIR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT IN A
CALLED. NONPARTISAN BARTLETT.
OTHER SHOULD NEVER IT COULD
WHEN CAPS A BALLOT IT SHOULD
NOT BE FOR UPON A NEW LOOK
ABOUT. SB THIRTY FIVE WILL HELP
BY EXTENDING THE NO ELECTION
NEARING BUFFERS DOWN FROM ONE
HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED FEET.
PROVIDING STRONGER VOTER ACCESS
AND PROTECTION TO ALL OUR
DROPBOX. SB THIRTY FIVE HELPS
MY OFFICE PROTECT ALL OUR
VOTERS FROM INTIMIDATION. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
VOTING IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
DEUS AND NEXT UP WE HAVE MS
CASTRO. HI GOOD MORNING I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS ROXANA CASTRO AND I'M A
COMMUNITY PROGRAM SPECIALIST
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
OF VOTERS. TODAY I AM
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE BECAUSE THIS BILL
WILL BRING NEEDED CLARITY AND
PROTECTION. ASSOCIATION
CONVENED A MEETING WITH LETTER
AND BURKE. WILL BE REVIEWED HOW
THE ELECTION WENT IN IDENTIFIED
POTENTIAL ISSUES WE SAW IN THE
FIELD DURING THE VOTING PERIOD.
WE DISCUSSED WITH SENATOR-
BURKE IN THE CONFUSION AT
VARIOUS VOTING LOCATIONS
REGARDING THE ELECTIONEERING
BUFFER. AT THE HONDA CENTER
WHICH WAS THE BOAT CENTER
SUPERSITE- THAT WAS ONE
LOCATION WHERE THE ISSUE OF
ELECTION BUFFER NEEDED MUCH
CLARITY. THERE WAS A LOCAL
CANDIDATE THAT WAS UNCLEAR
ABOUT ELECTIONEERING
INTERPRETER THE LONG AS
MEANINGFUL FOR ONE HUNDRED FEET
FROM THE ENTIRE VENUE. NOT FROM
THE ENTRANCE TO THE VOTING
GROWN. AT SOME VOTE PRINTERS WE
ALSO WITNESSED ISSUES WITH LONG
LINES DUE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS. BY VOTERS WERE
SUBJECT TO ELECTIONEERING
BECAUSE THEY WERE LINES THAT
EXTENDED BEYOND THE ONE HUNDRED
FOOT BUFFER. I BELIEVE THAT
CLARITY ALONG AN EXTENDED
PROTECTION THAT WILL MAKE THE
VOTING EXPERIENCE BETTER FOR
BOTH VOTERS AND ELECTION
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR HEARING MY TESTIMONY
TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ALL OF
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
CASTRO. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- I DON'T
SEE ANY PRIMER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- SO WE WILL NOW.
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTY FIVE AS A REMINDER
THE PUBLIC WELL FOR THIRTY
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL START
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB.
THIRTY FIVE. SEEING NONE- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
RATHER POSITION ON SB THIRTY
FIVE. SEEING ON WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDED THEIR POSITION ON
SB THIRTY FIVE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MEDICARE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF OR
OPPOSITION. OF SB THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MOMENT. LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR-
BURKE THIS IS TONY TRIGGER-
HAPPEN THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORTED B.
THREE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISTINA I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT LINE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE KEEP IT UP. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
YOUR MEMBERS PATRON WITH THE
KERN LEADING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN SCOTT
WITH PLASTER COUNTY FIRE CLOSE.
SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING TO REMEMBER THIS IS
STORE RECIPES RECTOR WOULD LEAD
ONE VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF A MEDICAL
MISSION WE JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ON BURKE AND OF OFFICE
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK IN
PROGRESS AND AMENDMENTS SEVEN
SURE. ENOUGH ABOUT COLLECTION
ACTIVITY ISN'T AN IMPORTANTLY
IMPEDED. THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS ERIC HARRIS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT SB THIRTY
FIVE AND WE THANK. PROFIT
AUTHOR FOUR DAYS OF WORK FOR
WORKING WITH US AND OUR TEAM
ALONG WITH SOME OF OUR
COALITION MEMBERS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH. THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS COMMON
CAUSE THEY FEEL YOU UP TO MAKE
THIS BILL AS STRONG AS POSSIBLE
FOR VOTERS WITH DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MY NAME'S
DEBORAH RITTENHOUSE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M DISABLED
I VOTE NO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND AT THIS TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU GREAT SO WE WILL MOVE
IT TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON SB THIRTY FIVE.
SEEING NINE. SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
TO THE WITNESSES MR DS AND MISS
CASTRO URGENT I'VE A GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE MANNER
IN WHICH CALIFORNIANS ARE
VOTING IS EVOLVING SO WE NEED
TO MODERNIZE THE RUSSIAN LAWS
THAT REFLECT VOTERS BEHAVIOR SB
THIRTY FIVE STRENGTHENS
ELECTION IN PROTECTIONS TO HELP
ENSURE THE VOTERS ARE NOT
DECEIVED BUT WOULD RETURN THE
BALLOT OR INTIMIDATED WHEN
TRYING TO VOTE. I RECOMMEND
SUPPORT WITH THE TECHNICAL AND
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOW
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED IN THE RIVER FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
BERMAN HI BERMAN I MATHIS
MATHIS KNOW BENNETT BENNETT HI
LO. LO I MAYES. MAY I. MULLIN I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU- I'M
SECRETARY CENTER THAT BILL IS
OUT SIXTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS GETTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON- TO
THE NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA AS
BEFORE FORTY TWO BY SENDER
NEWMAN CENTER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. THE BILL. GOT
A MOTION GOT A SECOND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RUSH TO A VOTE BECAUSE
WE HAVE A PROCESS IT TURNS OUT-
BUT CENTER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT. FIVE BYE BYE I'LL
DEFER TO SEND EMBRACE WISDOM
HERE I'LL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AND I BUT I DO HAVE TO WIN TWO
WITNESSES FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM- BUT
OTHER THAN THAT I'M I'M HERE TO
RESPECT ACTION I HOPE. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SANDERS SO
WILL WE WON'T GO TO THE
TECHNICAL WITNESSES BUT WE WILL
IF ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS COME
UP- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL MOVE. TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR. IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOR FORTY
TWO- I I'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT
WE NEED TO STAY THE TECHNICAL
IN THIS IS ARE THEY ARE MACHEL
WARSAW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF EDUCATION. AND
LARRY SHIREY ARE SURE RAY I
APOLOGIZE MY BUT YOUR LAST
NAME. ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU- MISTER VICE CHAIR AS A
REMINDER THE PUBLIC WHILE
THIRTY MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO WRITING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL START
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS JUST PROVIDE THE
POSITION ON THIS BEFORE. FORTY
TWO. SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
BERMAN IS OR ANYONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION WHICH
IS TO PROVIDE THE POSITION.
SEEING NONE. WE WILL NOW OVER
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON SB
FOUR FORTY TWO. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN-SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO US
BEFORE FORTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR FOUR TO. PRESS ONE ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR FORTY TWO. PERFECT ONE
ZERO NOW. MY NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE FUTURE. TONY TOOK
CARE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT
SO WE WILL NOT BRING BACK THE
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES DO YOU HAVE
ANY. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
I SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
BY APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE C. T. I. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE REQUIREMENT THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE VOTER
APPROVAL IN ORDER TO TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS HAS CREATED
CHALLENGES FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT. IN RESPONSE TO THESE
CONCERNS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN STEPS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO IT
THE TRANSITION TO DISOBEY
SELECTIONS THIS BILL HELPS
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO TRANSITION
TO DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS FOR
THESE REASONS I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HELLO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HIGHER EDUCATION BERMAN HI
BERMAN I MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
BENNETT BENNETT OUR LOW LOW I
MAYES MAYES MULLIN MULLIN I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO HI
GRANTS THAT BILL IT HAS A SAID
THE BILL PASSES WITH SEVEN
VOTE- AND WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT AND LAST BILL ON THE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SIX
SIXTY. BY THE GOOD CENTER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU AGAIN SO THAT
THAT WAS THE SHOW BEFORE THE
MAIN. FEATURE AND THIS WILL I
SUSPECT NOT BE NEARLY AS PRETTY
SO MISTER MEMBERS AYE I AM HERE
BEFORE YOU DID ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF SB SIX SIXTY. IT'S
PROVISIONS WILL PROHIBIT COMMON
PRACTICES IN THE GATHERING
SIGNATURES FOR BALLOT MEASURES
WHICH INCENTIVIZE THE WILLFUL
DECEPTION VOTERS IN SO DOING SB
SIX SIXTY WILL TAKE NECESSARY
AND IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARDS
SAFEGUARDING THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL
PROCESSES- BEFORE I BEGIN
PLEASE KNOW THAT I'M ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS- WITH
PARTICULAR APPRECIATION FOR THE
EAGLE EYED PERSON WHO SPOTTED
THE MISPLACED APOSTROPHE- IN
THE CAGED ON PAGE THREE LINE
THIRTY NINE IS. A SUSPECT WAS
EVEN THAT WHICH SHOULD HAVE
READ AS THE POSSESSIVE FORM OF
IT OF THE PLEURAL ATTORNEYS NOT
THE SINGULAR- BUT BACK TO THE
BILL NOW AS YOU MAY BE AWARE%
AND IF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
NOTES. CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF A
NUMBER OF STATES WHOSE
CONSTITUTIONS EXPRESSING
PROVIDED CITIZENS WITH TOOLS TO
DIRECTLY REDRESSED ABUSES OF
GOVERNMENT OR MALFEASANCE BY
PUBLIC OFFICIALS IN OUR CASE IN
THE FORM OF THE INITIATIVE THE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL- FIRST
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND CONTEXT.
THESE ADMIRABLE AND USEFUL
CONSTITUTION DIRECTOR MARK TO
PROVISIONS DATE BACK MORE THAN
A CENTURY AND ARE THE LEGACY OF
A GROUP OF PROGRESSIVE
REFORMERS LED BY THEN GOVERNOR
HIRAM JOHNSON. WHO WENT ON TO
BECOME CALIFORNIA'S LONGEST
SERVING REPRESENTED UNITED
STATES SENATE. THOUGH HIS
TWENTY YEARS IN OFFICE WAS
RECENTLY ECLIPSED BY OUR OWN
CENTER DIED FEINSTEIN. AS A
RESULT OF THE EFFORTS OF
GOVERNOR JOHNSON AND HIS
SUPPORTERS CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION THROUGH THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL MAKES EXPLICIT
PROVISIONS THROUGH THE UNIT
THAT MAKES EXPLICIT REYES THAT
ALLOW FOR THE CITIZENRY TO TAKE
ACTIONS. OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL
ELECTION LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
USED IN ORDER TO ENACT OR
REPEAL LEGISLATION OR TO REMOVE
A CORRUPT OR MALFEASANCE
ELECTED OFFICIAL FROM OFFICE.
TO THE ORIGINAL FRAMERS WAY OF
THINKING THE INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL
REPRESENTING MEANS FOR THE
LITTLE GUY TO ACHIEVE DIRECT
CURATIVE AND REFORMIST ACTIONS
THAT ELECTED INVESTED INTEREST
MIGHT OTHERWISE SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THE FRAMERS OF THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL REGARD THESE PROCESSES
AS POPULIST ACTIONS OF LAST
RESORT THEY DELIBERATELY
PROVIDED THAT IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT THE
PROPONENTS OF ANY OF. THESE
DIRECT TO THE VOTERS PLAY
BESIDES WOULD FOR FIRST BE RE.
TO GET A SHIFT NUMBER OF VOTERS.
IN IN SO DOING VALIDATE THE
LEGITIMACY AND POPULAR SUPPORT
FOR SUCH AN ACTION. OVER THE
YEARS ESPECIALLY IN RECENT
DECADES HOWEVER SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT. THAN THE FRAMERS
INTENDED HAS TRANSPIRED THESE
TOOLS OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY. HAVE
BEEN EFFECTIVELY CO OPTED. BY
THE VERY MONEYED INTERESTS THEY
WERE ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO
OFFSET. AS WELL FUNDED GROUPS
WITH INCREASINGLY EXPLICIT SELF
AND MOTIVATIONS. HAVE BECOME
EVER MORE ADEPT AT USING THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL PROCESS IS TO THEIR
BENEFIT. SOMETHING OF AN ARMS
RACE AROUND THESE PROCESSES HAS
ENSUED ESPECIALLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO SIGNATURE
GATHERING. AT THE CENTER OF
THESE EFFORTS THE SMALL NUMBER
OF SPECIALIZED FIRMS WITH
EXPERTISE IN SECURE GATHERING.
HAVE RISEN TO THE FORE OFFERING
THEIR SERVICES TO PROPONENTS.
SEEKING TO PLACE A MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT. ONE OF THE
PRINCIPAL TACTIC USED BY THE
SPECIALIZED TOGETHER INFERENCE
IS THE DEPLOYMENT OF WELL
TRAINED. PROFESSIONAL SIGNATURE
GATHERERS. TYPICALLY THE
SIGNATURE GATHERS ARE PAID ON A
PER SIGNATURE OR COMMISSION
BASIS. ALSO KNOWN AS THE
BOUNTY. AT A RATE DETERMINED BY
THE MARKET AS IT IS AS IT IS
SAYS AT THE TIME. DEPENDING ON
THE NATURE OF THE INITIATIVE
THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
DISTRICT. THE TIME OF YEAR
COMPETITION WITH OTHER NATIONS
AT ANY GIVEN TIME. THE COST PER
SIGNATURE FOR A- PARTICULAR
ISSUE CAN VARY WIDELY FROM AS
LOW AS TWO DOLLARS PER
SIGNATURE. GATHERED TO AS HIGH
AS TWENTY DOLLARS PER
SIGNATURE. AND BECAUSE BOUNTY
PAID SIGNATURE GATHERERS ARE
INCENTIVIZED OPTIMIZE. THEIR
YIELD BASED ON HOW RAPIDLY THEY
CAN SECURE SIGNATURES FOR
SIGNATURE FROM VOTERS. THEY
FRANKLY TRAFFIC AND
MISDIRECTION MEETING MISLEADING
INFORMATION AND OUTRIGHT
FALSEHOODS. IN ORDER TO INDUCE
AS MANY VOTERS AS POSSIBLE TO
SIGN. IN THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
TIME. AGAINST THIS BACKDROP THE
DETERMINING FACTOR GETTING A
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TOO OFTEN
HAS LESS TO DO WITH ITS POLICY
MERITS. THEN THE DEPTH OF A
PROPONENTS POCKETS OF COURSE
THIS IS EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
OF WHAT THE FRAMERS HAD MINE.
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF THESE
PERVERSE INCENTIVES THE PAPER
SIGNATURE SYSTEM. HAS IN FACT
SUBVERTED IN MANY CASES THE
ORIGINAL IDEALISTIC CONTENT OF
CALIFORNIA FOUNDERS. WHO
ENVISION A PEOPLE POWERED
SYSTEM OF REFERENDA AND
PROPOSITIONS VALIDATED BY
DEMONSTRATED PUBLIC SUPPORT.
AND WHICH X. OR FAIL ON THERE
MAY. NOT ON HOW WILL THE YSTEM
CAN GAMED. THE INITIAL
REFERENDUM A RECALL PROCESS
HE'S CAN AND SHOULD PLAY AN
IMPORTANT VALUE ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS AND
GOVERNMENT. IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
HOWEVER THAT UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. DRIVEN BY PROCEDURE
BOUNTIES. THERE ARE SCANT
PROSPECTS FOR DETERRING BAD
ACTORS WHO WILLFULLY MISLEAD
VOTERS AT THE EXPENSE. OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS. SB SIX SIXTY ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY PROHIBITING THE
PRACTICE OF PAYING SIGNATURE
GATHERS ON A PER SIGNATURE
BASIS. WHEN COLLECTING
SIGNATURES TO PLACE A STATE. OR
LOCAL INITIATIVE REFERENDUM A
RECALL ON THE BALLOT. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY
NOTES THIS MEASURE WOULD NOT
PROHIBIT PAYMENT FOR SIGNATURE
GATHERING OTHER WEIGHTS
TOGETHER STILL CULD BE PAID AN
HOURLY WAGE. OR SALARY OR OFFER
BONUSES BASED ON PERFORMANCE.
THIS GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE
WILL SERVE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RECALL REFERENDUM ISSUE PROCESS
BY ENSURING THAT VOTERS ARE
AWARE. OF EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
SIGNING AND NOT BEING DECEIVED
ULTIMATELY SB SIX SIXTY WILL
HELP TO RESTORE INTEGRITY. AND
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROVISIONS. FOR
DRAMATIC DIRECT DEMOCRACY THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE ASSURANCE.
AND TRANSPARENCY THE VOTERS AND
IT'S ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
WILL PERMIT BOTH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND ANY PERSON. TO
BRING A CIVIL CLAIM UNDER THE
SECTION FOR PROCEDURE PAYMENT
PRACTICES. EMPLOYERS VIOLATE
THE PROVISIONS OF SB SIX SIXTY
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A FINE OF
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OR FIFTY DOLLARS PER SIGNATURE
FRAUDULENT GET THIRD WHICHEVER
AMOUNT IS GREATER. OTHER STATES
SUCH AS COLORADO MONTANA AND
OREGON HAVE ALREADY EXAMINING
ISSUES SURROUNDING PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERS. AND HAVE IT
PLEDGES CAN PROHIBIT PERSINGER
BOUNTY PAYMENTS. REQUIRING
INSTEAD THE PAYMENT PROCEDURE
GETTING MAY ONLY BE MADE ON AN
HOURLY OR SALARY BASIS. IT IS
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO THE
SAME. OUR DEMOCRACY AND
GOVERNANCE WILL BE THE BETTER
FOR IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU CENTER. AND YOUR
PRESENT LAWCENTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT HE'S OUT
CLEARLY- NEXT TIME I WILL BE
BRIEF FOR. SO WE HAVE A- ONE
NOW MOVES TO- PRIMARY WITNESSES
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY PRIMER WHEN
THIS ISN'T SUPPORT- SO WE WILL
MOVE TO POWER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE- SHOW OF
MUHAMMAD. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. VIA PHONE-
MISTER MUHAMMAD IF YOU'RE THERE.
YES I AM YOU WEREN'T READY WHEN
YOU ARE- JUST A REMINDER YOU
HAVE. TO BELIEVE IT'S TWO
MINUTES- LET ME CONFIRM THAT
SOMEONE GETS THAT YEP TWO
MINUTES PERFECT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU HONORABLE CHAIR AND-
AND MEMBERS- MY NAME'S WHAT MOM
TO THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB SIX SIXTY WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL TO ADDRESS ELECTION
INTEGRITY THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS BILL DUE OUT WAY OUT OF
POTENTIAL BENEFITS THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED BY LANGUAGE. SB
SIX SIXTY INTENDS TO ADDRESS
ELECTION INTEGRITY BY
PROHIBITING SIGNATURE
COLLECTION ON A PARTICULAR
BASIS FOR STATE OR LOCAL
INITIATIVES REFERENDUMS THE
RECALL PETITIONS BY THE GREATER
BOB- TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
EVERY SIGNATURE GATHERED. BY
BANNING SIGNATURES GATHERING ON
A PER SIGNATURE BASIS THIS BILL
FORCES PEOPLE TO BEAR THE COST
OF HIRING OUR EMPOWER EXCUSE ME
HOURLY EMPLOYEES OR CONTRACTORS
WITH HOURLY EMPLOYEES TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES AND
DISINCENTIVE BY THOSE WORKERS
FROM COLLECTING THOSE
SIGNATURES BY DOING THAT SB SIX
SIXTY NOT ONLY SLOWS DOWN THE
GATHERING PROCESS BUT- MAKES A
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE. TO
CIRCULATE INITIATIVE OR RECALL
NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO PROPOSE A
REFERENDUM BUT IN ADDITION TO
CIVIL PENALTIES IN ADDITION TO
THE INCREASED COST OF
CIRCULATING A PETITION. SB SIX
SIXTY ALSO MAKE CALIFORNIA
BALLOT BOXES WITH THE RISK OF
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION BY
CREATING A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION TO ENFORCE ITS
PROVISIONS WHICH WOULD HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON THE BALLOT
PROCESS WITH THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION THERE IS A TANGIBLE
THREAT. THAT WELL FUNDED
LITIGATION DESIGNED TO
STRATEGICALLY TO PRESS PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION COULD SLOW THE
PROCESS ERODE THE PUBLIC TRUST
AND INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE CITIZEN LEVEL AFTER
IT'S BECOME BURDENED WITH
PREDATORY LAWSUITS AND JUDICIAL
INTERVENTION. THAT'S THE COST
OF EVERY INITIATIVE REFERENDUM
A RECALL PETITION WOULD NEED TO
ACCOUNT FOR SEPARATE FUNDING TO
DEFEND AGAINST THE POTENTIAL
FOR LAWSUITSBASED ON THIS
BILL. SB SIX SIXTY WOULD LEAVE
THE INITIAL PROCESS TO THE
DOMINION OF THOSE WHO HAVE THE
MONEY TO EMPLOYER AND
CONTRACTOR HOURLY WORKERS TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES AND WHO CAN
AFFORD TO DEFEND OR PROSECUTE
LAWSUIT REGARDING THE SAME.
FINALLY THE BILL ONCE FOR
DEMONSTRABLE PROOF OF FRAUD
STEMMING SPECIFICALLY FROM THE
PAYMENT PER SIGNATURE NOT THE
COLLECTION INDEED COMMITTEE AND
OUT OF SIGHT AND PERMISSION.
AND MAY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
APPROXIMATELY LAST TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS THE OFFICE IS OPEN
LOOKING THREE HUNDRED CASES FOR
POTENTIAL PETITION FRAUD OF
WHICH ONLY FIFTY FIVE WORK FOR
THE PROSECUTION DOES WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT SB SIX SIXTY IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS ELECTION
INTEGRITY WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WE THINK-
FOR ALLOWING US TO HER THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER MUHAMMAD.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SIXTY AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
OFF THIRTY MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL START
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO PROVIDE THE POSITION
ON SB SIX SIXTY. SEEING NOTHING
BUT SERGEANTS. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO- IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB SIX
SIXTY. SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE THERE ARE WILL NOW OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB
SIX SIXTY MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX SIXTY.
THANK YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OF SB
SIX SIX ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF SB SIX SIXTY
COULD PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY VALVE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIXTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWENTY
FIRST BUT LINE FOR SPEAKING
OPPOSITION TO SIX SIX ZERO
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WHICHEVER YOU PREFER. I
DEFINITELY PREFER OPPOSITION
OKAY SO WE'D LOVE TO GET YOUR
NAME ANY ORGANIZATION YOU'RE
WITH. I'M SORRY MY NAME YES
PLEASE. MY NAME IS A LEASE THAT
PEOPLE OKAY AND WHAT IS YOUR
POSITION WITH THE PEOPLE ON SB
SIX SIXTY. SHE MISTER OPERATORS
YOU CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WITH THE PEOPLE FOR YOUR
OPINION NUMBER NINETEEN. GOOD
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS THIS IS
YOUR DOOR ROADS LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA AND VERY
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
APPRECIATE THE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MS ROSE.
BY NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
STOCK WHERE CLUSTER CANDY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX SIX ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LIE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE AND I AM PROPOSING
THAT SINCE IT GOES AGAINST THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF AN ****
IGNITOR I OPPOSE IT STRONGLY.
THANK YOU JUST A REMINDER FOR
FOLKS IF YOU CAN PROVIDE YOUR
NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH IF YOU ARE WITH ONE
AND JUST YOUR POSITION SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS NICOLE
YOUNG AFRICAN PASTOR COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE OPPOSE SB SIX
SIXTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI YES MY NAME IS SHANNON HI
ALL I'M LEADING THE PACK COUNTY
FOR THE RECALL AND THEY
DEFINITELY OPPOSE THIS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DEBORAH RITTENHOUSE. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN AT THE TIME
OF DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU GREAT WILL BRING BACK
THE CALLS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS BELOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF CARE- SEND NEWMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING A SPORT
I HOPE YOU'LL ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE LEGISLATION I'M
WITH THE BILL. GOT A MOTION BUT
TO. GOT A SECOND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISMAS. SO
I'VE- THERE'S BEEN A COULE OF
BILLS- IN THE PAST- THAT- I DID
NOT BUT THE NOT SUPPORT- AND
I'M STILL NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
I'M GONNA DO WELL WHICH IS
WEIRD BECAUSE ABOUT TO TAKE A
VOTE. ON THIS BILL- THE REASON-
THERE'S A COUPLE REASONS THAT
I'M- THE FIVE ONE QUESTION IN
THE MAYBE WE GOT A STATEMENT
HERE TO IS- WHY PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION. WHY IS THAT
NECESSARY AND SO IT'S I THINK
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION SO WE HAVE
ADDED THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION I TO ADDRESS PRECISELY-
WHAT MR MAHAMA NOTED THAT THEY
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN RELATIVELY
FEW- COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATION
OF THE EURASIAN AND WE
ATTRIBUTE THAT FACT. TO THE
TRUE THAT MOST OF THOSE WHO ARE
IN POWER RIGHT NOW TO ENFORCE
EXISTING ELECTION CODE WHICH
MAKES IT EXPRESS ILLEGAL MAKES
IT A MISDEMEANOR TO ATTENTION
MISLEAD A VOTER AS TO THE
NATURE INTENT OF A CENTURY
RATIONS ABOUT MOST OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN POWER TO
ENFORCE THE LAW OR THEMSELVES
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
THEMSELVES POLITICAL ACTORS. AS
A RESULT THEY ARE THOROUGHLY
DISINCLINED TO INSERT
THEMSELVES INTO THIS PROCESS-
AND SO ALTHOUGH ANECDOTALLY WE
KNOW THE NUMBER OF. VIOLATIONS
IS OF A MAGNITUDE HIGHER-
THERE'S BEEN A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT- INTO THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO REALIGN THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE GET A GREATER LEVEL
OF ACCOUNTABILITY. I THERE'S
BEEN TO BE- A. B. NINETY FORTY
SO AND ALSO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
ONE THAT- THAT THE TIME TO DO
THIS VERY SAME THING ONE WAS. A
VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN THE
OTHER ONE WAS- VETOED BY
GOVERNOR SOME WISE THIS BILL
DIFFERENT. RIGHT YEAH I CAN I
THINK OF SOME OF THESE THINGS
TAKE TIME I THINK IS WORTH
NOTING THAT MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
LOWE'S IS THE AUTHOR OF
MOBILIZATION MADE THROUGH. THE
LEGISLATURE. AT THE EVIDENCE
OVER TIME HAS I THINK- A CREW
THAT DID THAT THIS IS NECESSARY
AND TWO MISSED SOME MISTER
HOBBS COMMENTS. IT IS NOT TRUE
OR CERTAINLY NOT TO MOST WHICH-
THAT THIS WOULD INCREASE THE
COST OF ELECTIONS- WHAT IT
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD INCREASE
THE ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN. YOU
KNOW SINGS GETTING PROCESS-
THAT IS A GOOD THING AND I
SUSPECT THIS GOVERNOR HAS SEEN
FIRST HAND. HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS AND- I AM HOPEFUL THAT IF
AND WHEN THIS BILL NEXT TO HIS
DESK ON THIS OCCASION- THAT
HE'S INCLINED TO SIGN I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT AS I'VE DONE.
INVESTMENT HEARINGS THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IMPACT. ON THE CURRENT RECALL
EFFORT AGAINST THIS GOVERNMENT
SERVICES MEANT. TO MOVE
FORWARD- MATTER- TO THE AS I
SAID TO IMPLEMENT A BETTER
INTEGRITY ACCOUNTABILITY. OKAY
I DO NOT BUT THE REASON WHY
I'M- INSTEAD OF JUST A JUST
OPPOSE THIS OUT RIGHT NOW I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS A BIT- IS
SAID RECENTLY- I WAS. INFORMED
ABOUT- A GENTLEMAN DOWN IN. I
ONE OF MY TO COUNTIES- WHO WAS
OUT COLLECTING- A TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO REGISTER FOR A NEW
POLITICAL PARTY. AND- WHEN- MY
FRIEND WALKED IN- TO THE STORE.
THIS GENTLEMAN HAD SAID- YOU
KNOW WOLD YOU PLEASE- EVERY
REGISTRY NEED TO RE REGISTER-
AND SO- I THIS PART IN BACK OUT
AGAIN. I FOUND ANOTHER A LADY
WHO WAS- RE REGISTERING AND- I
WONDER THEY RE REGISTERING
ACTUALLY- MY CHECK. CHECK THE
BOX- OTHER. UNDER THE PARTY AND
THEN IT WAS GOING TO WRITE IN
THE NAME. OF THIS NEW UP PUT
POLITICAL PARTY- AND WAS
TELLING US. THAT THIS LADY THAT
THIS WAS REQUIRED AND THERE
ACTUALLY WAS WITH RAGING IS
INDEPENDENT. THE INDIVIDUAL
GETTING PAY. ON A PER RIDE
REGISTRATION REGISTRATION BASIS
SO TO YOUR PROBLEM TO THE
PROBLEM THAT'S HERE THERE'S A
LOT OF BAD ACTORS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU FIX
THAT- AND- I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS THE ANSWER A BUT THERE
CERTAINLY DOES NEED TO BE. BE A
FIX BECAUSE THERE ARE BAD
ACTORS THAT ARE OUT THAT ARE-
THAT ARE TELLING PEOPLE- ONE
THING- AND- I JUST SO THAT THEY
CAN GET GET GET PAID AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOUR- INTENT
IS BUT I JUST THINK THERE'S
SOME ISSUES. I'M HERE WITH THIS
AT THIS BILL SO I APPRECIATE
THAT ASSEMBLY MINNESOTA THAT IS
PRECISELY. MY INTENT- AND I
THINK THAT YOU'VE- WELL
ARTICULATED A TYPICAL USE CASE-
WORKWHERE THAT SIGNATURE
GATHER. IF THEY WERE NOT BEING
PAID PER SIGNATURE GATHERED.
WOULD NOT BE ACTING IN THAT
FASHION- AND IF YOU CAN REMOVE
THAT DISTORTING INCENTIVES.
FROM THE SINGER GETTING
PROCESS. YOU CAN YOU CAN RETURN
THE ASSURANCE TO VOTERS THAT IF
AND WHEN WE MEET THE THRESHOLD
RIGHT FOR ANY OF THE THREE.
PLAY BESIDES THE RECALL THE
INITIAL RUN RUN RUN. WHEN WE
MEET THAT THRESHOLD THAT IS
THAT WAS MEANT TO BE THE PROOF.
OF THE VALIDITY OF THE ACTION
WHERE YOU INTRODUCE YOU KNOW
THIS IS SYSTEMIC INCENTIVES-
AND HOT YOU KNOW HIRE
PROFESSIONALS TO GATHER
SIGNATURES AND THEY THEY THEY
ALIGN THEIR WORK WITH THOSE
INCENTIVES. YOU YOU LOSE THAT
LEGITIMACY. WITH THE MEETING OF
THE THRESHOLD. I DIE SAID IS
TRUE PROBLEM- AND I AND I LIKE
POINT OUT THE NINETY TWELVE
WHEN HIRAM JOHNSON AND HIS
FOLKS GOT THIS PAST. NOBODY
WENT TO THE DRY GOOD STORE WITH
A CLIPBOARD. AND NOBODY USED
DIGITAL MEDIA TO COLLECT MONEY
TO PAY PROFESSION SO YOU GOT
THIS. SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS ALIGNED YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
THE MODERN WORLD WITH THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
REFORMERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ON. THANK YOU
MISMAS SEEING ANY OTHER OR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES WHO GOT MOTION GOING
TO SECOND MISTER CENTER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT BY THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TODAY
GREAT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I THINK- AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
MAYES ON THIS BILL I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOU CENTER FOR
KNOWLEDGE AND- IN TYPICAL
FASHION. THAT AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS CASE MR LOW DID
ALL THE WORK AND THAT YOU ARE
SWEEPING AND MOPPING UP RIGHT.
AT THE END. OF IT BUT I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE I
WISH YOU BETTER LUCK. WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND I'M HAPPY TO- TO-
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY NON
SECULAR HE PLEASE CALL OVER THE
VOTE. THE MOST IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I MATHIS. MATHISNO
BENEFITS. LOW HI WELL HIGH
MAYES. MAYES IS NOT VOTING
MULLIN. MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO
BONTA RUBIO I. FOUR ONE SO THAT
BILL- IS OUT FORTY ONE BUT
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. IF YOU THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK CENTER. AND WE WILL ALL-
REACH OUT TO MISTER BENNETT'S
OFFICE TO SEE IF HE'S ABLE TO
MAKE IT BACK TO ADD ON BT IN
THE MEANTIME. A COUPLE OF
BILLS- YEAH- YEAH WE'RE GONNA
ADD ON THE CONSENT. OKAY SB
FIVE NINETY FIVE ALLEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS S AMENDED TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MAYES FIVE
MAYES I MULLIN. MULLIN HI. THAT
GIVE THE CONSENT- IS OUT. SEVEN
TWO ZERO. AND ONLY ONE MORE
MISSING THIS MISTER BENNETT ON-
SIX SIXTY GRAND I BELIEVE- US
WHENEVER BENNETT IS PRESENTING
IN THE SENATE SO WEWILL LEAVE-
I WILL HANG OUT AND GIVE US A
BETTER TIME TO COME IN TO ADD
ON. TO SIX SIXTY. THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY BUT THE MEETING IS
NOT YET ADJOURNED. THE RECORD.
YES YES ABOUT FORTY FOUR VOTE
SO.
THAT NO I DON'T.
DO THAT
HOPEFULLY ALL THE MICE ARE
WORKING NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT WE KEPT EVERYTHING.
OPEN FOR YOU TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON TO IT SB
SIX SIXTY. FOR SO ADDING ON THE
S. AND SIX SIXTY NEWMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- BENNETT HI SENATE I
PUT IN THAT BILL IS AT OUT
WHAT'S THE UPDATED TALLY NOW.
TWO ONE FIVE TWO ONE AND I HOPE
YOU HAD GOOD LUCK IN IN THAT
WITH WITH OUR- THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE SENATE WILL I WISH YOU
LUCK. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT OUR
MEETINGS ADJOURN THINGS
EVERYONE.